SIMPLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IT
IT'S TUESDAY JANUARY.
SECOND TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN.
HAPPY NEW YEAR WELCOME BACK TO
EVERYONE WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
BILLS TODAY. WE DO NOT YET HAVE
A QUORUM BUT WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE SINCE WE HAVE
ENOUGH TO DO THAT.
DOCTOR REGULAR.
IT'S YOUR HERE YOUR UP FIRST
WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN.
MORNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
I AM PRESENTING AB TWELVE EIGHTY
NINE AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT SPENT
EXTENSIVE HOURS NEGOTIATING THE
LANGUAGE THAT IS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY.
I ESPECIALLY LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE. AND THE SPONSORS TO
CRAFT LANGUAGE THAT WILL ALLOW
THE UPDATING OF THE CIVIL CODE
SECTION AS IT RELATES TO REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTIONS.
AS IT NOW STANDS AB TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE MAKES NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES AND
MODERNIZE IS THE REAL ESTATE
LAW.
AND WILL PROVIDE GREATER CLARITY
TO CONSUMERS AND PRACTITIONERS
REGARDING TERMINOLOGY
DEFINITIONS AND EXISTING
PRACTICE.
SOME OF THE ORIGINAL LANGUAGE
WITH RESPECT TO AGENCY WHILE NOT
INTENDING TO BE CONTROVERSIAL.
TURNED OUT TO BE
AND WE HAVE WORKED WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE COMMITTEE
ON THESE ISSUES AND ACCEPT
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO ALLAY
THOSE CONCERNS.
THE BILL WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS CONTINUES TO RESOLVE
MATTERS OF IMPORTANCE TO THE
CONSUMERS AND PRACTITIONERS IN
THIS AREA. IT CONSOLIDATES TERMS
SO THAT USAGE IS MORE
UNDERSTANDABLE SUCH AS.
REPLACING TRANSFER WITH SELLER.
IT REMOVES ARCHAIC TERMS
REPLACING THE CONFUSING TERM
SELLING AGENT BY BUYER'S AGENT
FOR AN AGENT OF THE BUYER.
IT MAKES NON CONTROVERSIAL
AMENDMENTS
TO CLARIFY ISSUES WITH EXISTING
DISCLOSURE LAW.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THE
CONCERNED ABOUT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ARE ADDRESSED IN
THAT THE BILL REMAINS NON
CONTROVERSIAL AS STATED. I
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE AND IN
SUPPORT AND TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS I HAVE
SUNDAY WHILE GOAL WITH THE
REALTORS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PUT JEFF
STONE IN MEMBERS THANK YOU I AM
SANTIAGO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND WE
SUPPORT AND ARE PROUD SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL. I'M NOT GONNA GO
AHEAD AND.
REPEAT WHAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OF REGULAR
CREATED A REGARDING THE BILL. I
DO WANT TO JUST REITERATE THAT
THAT THE AUTHOR AND OUR
ORGANIZATION OF HELD A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS
AT THIS BILL IN PRINT INVITED
PARTICIPANTS TO SUGGEST LANGUAGE
AND PROVIDE CRITIQUES OF ANY
PARTS OF THE BILL THAT RAISED
ISSUES.
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ARE
MEANT TO ADDRESS NOW LAY ANY
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE COMMITTEE.
AND IN PARTICULAR I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ITS WORK WITH US.
THERE ARE SOME OUTSTANDING
ISSUES I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
WE INTEND TO CONTINUE THIS
TRANSPARENT AND OPEN PROCESS
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF.
TO MAKE SURE REMAINING CONCERNS
AND OUTSTANDING ISSUES ARE
ADDRESSED IN THAT THE SORT OF
CONSENSUS PRODUCT REMAINS.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL ARE THE QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AND IT WAS HIS SUPPORT SING NOT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SINGER.
MIKLOS.
I AM BOTH HUMBLY REQUEST
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU THINK.
SO WE HAVE ONE MORE.
AUTHOR BUT ALSO.
FEW MEMBERS WE NEED TO
COLLECT
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE OUR SECOND
AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SO WE MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TEN FIFTY NINE.
GONZALEZ LETTER.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB TEN FIFTY NINE A
SIMPLY IMPROVE THE DISCLOSURE
WHEN OF REAL ESTATE BROKER OR
AGENT REPRESENTS BOTH SIDES OF
THE COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTION KNOWN AS DUAL
AGENCY.
THIS ARRANGEMENT IT'S BECOME
COMMONPLACE IN REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTIONS AND CAN LACK THE
CHECKS AND BALANCES THAT OCCUR
WHEN A SELLER BUYER. OR LESSER
IN MY SEAT EACH HAVE THEIR OWN
REPRESENTATION DURING A
TRANSACTION.
CURRENTLY THERE'S A LONG AND
CONFUSING DISCLOSURE THAT
SUGGEST THAT DOLE AGENTS HAVE
FIDUCIARYRESPONSIBILITY BOTH
THE BUYER AND THE SELLER.
IT'S A VERY SMALL FONT AND AS
YOU CAN SEE I HAVE A COPY IF I
CAN SHOW YOU.
OF THIS IS.
THE COMPLETE DISCLOSURE TO TELL
SOMEBODY THAT THEY OR THEIR
AGENT IS ACTUALLY REPRESENTING.
BOTH SIDES OF THE TRANSACTION
FOR THOSE OF YOU HER ATTORNEYS
COMMITMENT IF THAT'S ALL YOU'RE
GETTING I'M.
HOW CLEAR THAT IT'S IT'S ALSO
BEGIN GET IT THERE'S A LOT
FLEXIBILITY IN WHEN IT CAN BE
GIVEN AND SO IT'S BEEN GIVEN AT
A TIME WHEN A NUMBER OTHER
DISCLOSURES OFTEN ARE GIVEN AND
NOT GIVEN THE PROPER WEIGHT
PROBABLY TO ENSURE? THAT THE
TENANT AS WELL THE LANDLORD HAS
BEEN ADEQUATELY REPRESENTED
UNDERSTAND THE POTENTIAL FOR
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
WHAT THIS WOULD DO IS SIMPLIFY
THIS FORM?
IT WOULD BE AND FOURTEEN POINT
POT IT SIMPLY.
DECLARE THAT THAT THE THE AGENTS
THE LESSEE IS REPRESENTING BOTH
SIDES OF THE DEAL SO THAT THE
TENANT ESPECIALLY TENANTS WERE
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE STOREFRONT
OPERATIONS CAN BE CLEAR THAT
THEY'RE BEING REPRESENTED BOTH
BY THE PERSON REPRESENTING THE
LANDLORD. AND THE TENANT IT
WOULD ALSO HAVE TO BE GIVEN AT A
TIME WHEN THE TRANSACTION STARTS
NOT JUST WHEN THE REST OF THE
DISCLOSURES ARE GIVEN. I THINK
THIS IS SIMPLE IT'S CLEAR IT'S
THAT IT'S JUST TO ENSURE THE
PEOPLE ARE ADEQUATELY I'M.
ENSURE THAT THEY KNOW WHAT IS
MOVING FORWARD AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR HIGH BUT I
THINK I HAVE SOME. FOLKS WHO ARE
GOING TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I DON'T.
SEEING NONE NO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATTHEW
HARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
WE FIRST WANT TO START OUT BY
THANKING THE AUTHOR WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT HOW FAR THIS
BILL IS COME. AND WE SPENT MUCH
TIME OVER THE CHRISTMAS HOLIDAYS
AND THE NEW YEAR'S HOLIDAYS
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF AND
OTHER FOLKS ON THIS BILL. AT THE
LANGUAGE THAT YOU SEE BEFORE YOU
NOW IS A GREAT IMPROVEMENT IN
OUR OPINION THAT WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH AUTHOR ON.
FIXING SOME OF IT OUR MAIN
CONCERN WITH THE BILL AT THIS
POINT IS IT'S REQUIRING A THIRD
DISCLOSURE WHICH WE FEEL IS AND.
.
MORE THAN IT IS NECESSARY FOR
FOLKS UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'RE IN
A DUAL AGENCY SITUATION. AND AS
WE AND WE HAVE A GREAT CONCERN
ABOUT WHEN THAT GETS TRIGGERED.
WE THINK AS A LANGUAGE IS
WRITTEN RIGHT NOW IT POTENTIALLY
HOUSE A GOTCHA IN TO GET IT
POTENTIALLY GETS.
ASSN AGENTS IN TROUBLE BECAUSE.
YOU DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHEN THAT
THIRD DISCLOSURE SUPPOSE TO
HAPPEN SO WITH THAT AGAIN WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. AT BUT AT THIS
POINT COMPANY BITS PROPERTY
ASSOCIATION IS IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
THAT MORNING ONE SECOND IF YOU
WOULD MEAN WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
OF LIKE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
STONE.
HERE CUNNINGHAM CHAO.
CHIU GARCIA.
HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY THEIR.
MAINTAIN. PRESS.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM AND I WILL
NOTE FOR THE RECORD THAT ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB TEN FIFTY SIX
MISTER KYLIE'S BEEN PULLED FROM
THE CALENDAR. AND ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE
MISTER BERMAN IS OUR PROPOSED
CONSENT ITEM.
ALRIGHT NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING TARA MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRISTINE DUGGAR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WE ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF FOR WORKING SO
CLOSELY WITH A FROM THE SPELL.
AND WE NEED TO REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS IT
STANDS NOW. CURRENTLY WE HAVE TO
UP REAL ESTATE LAW CLEAN UP
BILLS THAT ARE GOING TO THE
PROCESS ONE OF WHICH THIS
COMMITTEE JUST HEARD. AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO BY THE AUTHOR TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE ONGOING
STAKEHOLDER DISCUSSIONS THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING WE THINK
DISCLOSURE WOULD BE A VERY
RELEVANT PART OF THAT CLEANUP.
BUT AS IT STANDS NOW AND THE
BILL REALLY CREATES
A DUPLICATIVE REQUIREMENT I'M
WERE NOT SURE THAT IT ACTUALLY
WILL OCCUR AT ANYTIME SOONER IN
THE TRANSACTION SO IT MAY NOT
ACHIEVE WHAT IT'S ATTEMPTING TO
ACHIEVE.
DISCLOSURES AS THEY STAND NOW
ON AGENCY ARE REQUIRED TO BE
PRESENTED TO THE BUYER.
OR THE LAW LASSIE UP PRIOR TO
AN OFFER BEING MADE.
.
THEY SPELL IT WOULD REQUIRE THEM
TO BE MADE AT SOME POINT AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE AFTER LICENSE
ACTIVITY BEGAN. IS THAT AGENCY
IS THAT A YOU UNPLUG WHAT
RELATIONSHIP IS THAT I'M WERE
JUST UNCLEAR WE DON'T THINK THE
BILL'S FULLY COOKED WE INVITE
YOU TO BE A PART OF OUR
STAKEHOLDER DISCUSSIONS AND
HOPEFULLY INCLUDE THAT AT. YOUR
DISCLOSURE CONCERNS IN OUR BILLS
WE DO SUPPORT VIC CLEAR AGENCY
DISCLOSURE. OUR ORGANIZATION
SPONSORED THE ORIGINAL AGENTS
LEGISLATION WE JUST DON'T THINK
THAT THIS IS IN PROPER FORM.
BUT I THINK OUR POST.
AND WHAT ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
S. COME FORWARD AND GIVE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE
.
BUT B. ARIAS.
ALREADY HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
INVESTIGATE IT ART THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
NEXT IN OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD
JUST GIVE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION CHONG LEWIS OF THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
REPRESENTING TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
BUSINESS OWNERS ALSO OPPOSED.
AND NOW OVERWROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE BUILDING OWNERS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
REX W. HYMAN BEHALF OF
INTERNATIONAL COUNCIL SHOPPING
CENTERS ALSO OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING STEVE CREATURE NAY
UP CALIFORNIA.
BARBARA GOT ON BEHALF OF CBRE
INTERNATIONAL.
IN OPPOSITION.
IT WOULD ALSO OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SEEING NONE.
I THINK NOW MY SPONSOR IS HERE
IF I COULD THAT I KNOW THAT'S
OUT OF ORDER MINDS THEN IT IS
OUT OF ORDER BUT OF ALL TAKE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT SINCE THERE
WAS NO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT IF
IT'S BRIEF PLEASE THANK HIM.
WHENEVER ONE.
MORNING.
SO.
IN TERMS OF WHAT THIS IS DOING
IS RIGHT NOW IT'S.
AND JASON USE HIS MARINO.
.
THE DISCLOSURE AS IT CURRENTLY
STANDS DOES NOT.
.
WORK VERY WELL
FOR LACK OF BETTER WORDS.
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
IN REAL PRACTICE
GET THIS OUT THERE FOR THE
CONSUMER THAT DOESN'T KNOW
BETTER.
AND ARE NOT BEING TOLD WHAT THE
POTENTIAL.
CHALLENGES AND UC CONFLICTS
MIGHT BE.
SO RIGHT NOW IN PRACTICE IT'S
NOT BE DISCLOSED UNTIL.
TYPICALLY THE VERY AND WHEN ALL
THE DOCUMENTS ARE SIGNED IN ITS
TYPICALLY A STACK OF.
COULD BE HUNDRED PAID OUT PAGES
AND A MULTIPLE SIGNATURES.
SO.
REALLY THE WHOLE DO AGENCIES
SHOULD BE BANNED ALTOGETHER.
BARRING THAT AT THE VERY LEAST
IT SHOULD BE HAVE BETTER
DISCLOSURE WHICH IS ALL WE'RE
ASKING FOR THIS POINT.
THANK.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SPORTS.
ALRIGHT SING NONE OF BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COME.
THINK THINK I'VE GOT ICE I
MISSED.
THE TESTIMONY.
EARLIER AND I JUST CALLED A
PIECE AND SO YOU MIGHT BE
REPEATING SOMETHING THAT AREA
SAID SOMETHING BELCHING FROM.
THERE WITH BUT I DID CATCH AND
OF
A COMMENT ABOUT.
I I HAD MISSED THAT PRINTS OUT
THE CURRENT DISCLOSURE HARM. A
HAVE A COPY AS WELL YEAH AND AND
AND I AND I. AND I'M LATE TO DO
MY HOMEWORK STYLES WITH RELATING
TO THIS CLOSE THAT BUT I WAS
READING THAT DISCLOSURE THAT'S
IN HERE.
IN ADDITION TO WHICH IS.
MY QUESTION IS THERE WAS A
COMMENT OF.
WHETHER IT DIED FAKE THAT AT
MINES AND IS CORRECT IT'S TWO
PIECE RIGHT NOW IT'S WE MOVE UP
DISCLOSURE.
A TO TO GUARANTEE THAT A CERTAIN
SPOT I'M NOT AGAIN LIKE YOU'RE
SAYING. AND WE CHANGE WITH THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S BEING FAT.
I THINK WE CLARIFIED IF YOU LIKE
IT AT AND TO MAKE IT HERE SO
THAT.
I JUST THOUGHT.
SO YEAH YOU GET SIMPLY THAT'S
WHEN YOU ENTER INTO THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH.
THE DILIGENT.
WE AT A SO THAT THERE FOR THEM
MY MY QUESTION.
AND AN I POD IS THAT THE
OPPOSITION HAS LEFT.
BUT YOU YOU COULD TALK AND IF I
CAN MAYBE GET DEPOSITION IS IS
THERE DISCUSSIONS OF.
WHAT WOULD BE IN IN THE LINE
WHICH IS I FEEL THERE'S A LOT
WAS PIECE AND THERE'S A TINY
PIECE BUT SO WE FOR EVEN TALK
ABOUT TIGHTENING ON THE LINE
WITH PEACE? SHUT NEGOTIATIONS
BEEN HAPPENING ON THAT I.
I HEARD AT THE VERY END ABOUT WE
WANT TO KEEP WORKING. WITH
THE OTHER NUMBER THAT I AM NOT
SURE WHAT THAT MEANS IS I MEAN A
WHOLE YOU BILL AND SOME TO
STRAIN THROUGHOUT THE MEANS FROM
YOU AND FROM THEM.
SO I APOLOGIZE THEY CAME IN
FULLY TO THE DISCUSSION FOR ME.
AYE I HAVE AT THIS BILL IN FACT
IS A TO YOUR BILL AT A TRUE TO
YOUR BILL THIS ISN'T A I GOT A
MAN AND WE HAVE.
COMPLETELY REDUCE THIS JUST TO
DISCLOSURE I'VE HAD TALKS WITH
THE OPPOSITION AND MY OFFICE I'M
DURING THE BREAK WE HAVE
CONTINUED I KNOW THE CHAIR HAS
HAS TALKED AT LENGTH. I'M WITH
ALL PARTIES ABOUT THIS ISSUE
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT'S TIMELY
THERE IS I'M. A I NEED TO HEAD
TO ACT ON THIS IDEA OF CONFLICT
OF INTEREST BECAUSE OF SUPREME
COURT YOU KNOW AND SO WE HAVE TO
IT WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN.
INSURE ODD THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND I'LL
ALTHOUGH A LOT OF THE EXAMPLES.
THERE'S A LITTLE DISCONNECT I'M
A LOT EXAMPLES THAT WERE
PRESENTED TO ME ARE A BIG LAW
FIRM WHOSE RENTING SPACE OF
COURSE IN A LARGE BUILDING IN
WHICH CASE I'M I'M A LITTLE LESS
CONCERNED THAT THEY HAVE TO READ
THE DISCLOSURE AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
WHO I AM?
REPRESENT IN MY DISTRICT ARE ARE
MUCH SMALLER BUSINESSES OFTEN
WITH LANGUAGE BARRIERS TO.
DON'T UNDERSTAND QUITE WHAT'S
GOING ON EXCEPT THAT THEY'RE
WORKING WITH AN AGENT TO FIND
LEASABLE SPACE AND AND.
AT THE END TO GET THIS ALONG
WITH I THINK IT'S AN EIGHT PAGE
DISCLOSURE DOCUMENT.
ST BAIT THEY'VE BEEN INFORMED
THAT THEY THAT THE PERSON WHO IS
I'M ACTING AS THEIR THERE ARE
AGENT IS ALSO ACTING AS AGENTS
OF THE LANDLORD.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR AND
I AM OPEN OF COURSE I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH AND THEY HAVEN'T
SUGGESTED ANY CHANGE IN IN
LANGUAGE THEY HAVEN'T SUGGESTED
ANY CHANGE IN THIS BILL.
AT IT IT'S KIND OF HARD TO WORK
WITH A OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
WHEN YOU DON'T REALLY HAVE.
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS BUT I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK OBVIOUSLY THIS IS AT A
PROCESS THAT IS IN THE FIRST
HOUSE AT THE FIRST HEARING TO BE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT.
SIR.
SO IF WE OPPOSITION WHO.
IT'S GOING TO COME ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THE I'M SORRY ON THE LANGUAGE
AND THE ON THE LINE WITH HE'S
NOT THE TIMING. AND DURING THE
STAKEHOLDER DISCUSSIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD THIS FAR WITH
COMMITTEE WITH THE AUTHOR STOP
AND WE WERE STILL DEALING WITH A
BILL THAT WAS IN A FULL BAR DULY
AGENCIES. AND SO WE HAVE BEEN
MOSTLY NEGOTIATING GETTING IT
BACK YOU KNOW. PAIRING THIS DOWN
SIGNIFICANTLY WE HAVEN'T YET
GOTTEN TO A PLACE WHERE WE HAVE
DISCUSSED LANGUAGE WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE AS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED. I'M WE THINK THAT IN
SOME WAYS IT DEMONIZED AS TO
AGENCIES WHEN IT REALLY.
IT IN STATUTE WHICH WE THINK IS
INAPPROPRIATE UP AND DIDN'T. AND
SO AGAIN AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
WE HAVE TWO BILLS THAT ARE
MOVING RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
CLEANING UP THE REAL ESTATE LAN
BUT THE CIVIL GOOD BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE. AND WE INVITE
WITH THIS WOULD BE AN ABSOLUTELY
OF THOSE BILLS IN BOTH OF THOSE
SPELLS WE WOULD ABSOLUTELY
INVITE AND AUTHORED HER STOPPED
CONTINUE. ENGAGING IN
STAKEHOLDER CONVERSATIONS ON
THOSE WE JUST DON'T THINK THAT
THIS BILL IS COOKED READY TO GO
AND IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
WE DON'T THINK THAT IT'S GOING
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEMS THAT IT
ATTEMPTS TO.
BUT THE QUESTION.
TO MAKE.
THIRTIES GO.
NO GARDENS CUNNINGHAM OKAY.
THANK YOU I JUST HAVE A COUPLE
QUICK QUESTIONS ON THE PENALTY
SECTION I THINK IT'S SECTION DE.
OF IN THE.
AMENDED MARKUP LANGUAGE.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S
OTHER.
OTHER AREAS OF LOS SOMEWHERE IN
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE MAYBE WERE THE BUREAU OF
REAL STATE HAS THE AUTHORITY.
TO PENALIZE.
.
AGENTS FOR NON COMPLIANCE WITH
THEIR ITS REQUIREMENTS
AND THIS SEEMS TO ADD A NEW
SECTION THAT CALLS FOR.
DISCIPLINE INCLUDING.
FORFEITURE OF LICENSE AND I.
I GUESS I.
I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND FOR A
WILLFUL VIOLATORS A REPEAT
OFFENDER WHY THAT WOULD MAYBE BE
APPROPRIATE OR. OF SOMEONE WHO'S
GOT A RECORD OF.
IT'S SORT OF BLOWING OFF
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS THAT
THERE.
UNDER THE LAW.
.
BUT I THINK THE BUREAU REAL SAY
AYE I MAY BE WRONG BUT I'D LIKE
TO HEAR FROM ME BOTH SIDES ABOUT
WHETHER IT'S ACCURATE I THINK TO
BE A REAL REAL SAID ALREADY HAS
THE POWER TO DO THAT.
AND SO I'M WONDERING IF THE
SECTION DE IS.
EVERY GUY GETS CONCERT TAKEN OUT
OF THE BILL.
IT SEEMS LIKE.
FORFEITURE OF LICENSE FOR.
AN INADVERTENCE NONDISCLOSURE OR
A FIRST TIME OFFENSE JUST
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE THE
APPROPRIATE. PENALTY TO MAKE.
AND
AT SUCH AS THE.
ON A THREAT OUT THERE I AGREE
AND I THINK PART.
ACTUALLY JUST RESTATED WHAT THE
POSSIBLE PENALTY WOULD BE
SO OKAY WE CAN CROSS REFERENCE
IT THAT'S BETTER.
SO OKAY SO THE INTENT IS IT'S
NOT ADDING THAT DO NOT HAVE
EIGHTY NINE IT NOW OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S UP TO TO YOU KNOW IN A
DEGREE JUST CASE BECAUSE
THERE'S.
OTHER FACTORS IT'S NOT ENOUGH
FOR ME TO DECIDE BUT I I AGREE
WITH YOU ANNA. IN A CASE IT'S
INCIDENTAL THAT'S NOT WHAT WAS
INTENDED.
OKAY.
AND THEN MY OTHER QUESTION WAS
JUST.
IT THIS IS JUST FOR A COMMERCIAL
RIGHT YES.
OKAY I.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT SEEMS LIKE
THE PROBLEM WOULD BE MORE ACUTE
IN THE ON THE RESIDENTIAL SIDE
IN THE COMMERCIAL IS BECAUSE.
THE TYPES OF PEOPLE TO GET INTO
THOSE TRANSACTIONS I MEAN MAYBE
I'M WRONG BUT. JUST CURIOUS WHY
WOULDN'T DEFINITELY IS PROBABLY
GONNA WILL. FOR THE PROMISE
COMMERCIAL YOU'RE DEALING WITH
IT INSTITUTION MULTIBILLION
DOLLAR INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
REPRESENTED THIS IS THEIR
PROFESSION.
HEY THERE THEY MIGHT HAVE FOR
EXAMPLE CBRE. EITHER OWNS OR
CONTROLS TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
SQUARE FEET OF COMMERCIAL SPACE
THAT'S EQUAL TO EVERY OFFICE
BUILDING ON THE WHOLE WESTERN
HALF OF THE U. S..
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF PROPERTY.
YOU KNOW A GROUP LIKE THAT IS
VERY VERY SOPHISTICATED WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND THEY WORK
TOGETHER. TO HELP THEIR CLIENTS
THEIR CONSTITUENTS WHICH I
LANDLORDS PRIMARILY IT REPRESENT
A LOT OF LOT ATTENDANTS TO BUT.
A LOT OF THOSE ARE IN DUAL
AGENCY CONFLICTED ROLES.
WE THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT THESE TENANTS WHO CAN BE.
A DRY CLEANER OR A DELI OR A
COFFEE SHOP ALL THE WAY UP TO
THE LARGEST FIRMS OUT THERE.
THEY AT LEAST BE AWARE THAT
THERE'S THAT POTENTIAL OF
CONFLICT.
THAT EVERYBODY'S YOU NEED IT
ACTING EGREGIOUSLY JUST THERE'S
THAT POTENTIAL IN THAT SHOULD
JUST BE A LITTLE BIT MORE WHERE.
AND SO I AGREE WITH YOUR
ASSUMPTION THAT THERE'S
PROBABLY.
OTHER PROBLEMS WITH A REAL
ESTATE AT. AT NIGHT SORRY I
DON'T KNOW THE TERM THE PER A
PERSONAL REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTION.
R. HOME BUYERS BAD BUT THIS IS
A.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THINGS I THINK
THEY'RE DEALING WITH IN THESE
OMNIBUS BILLS THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH NOW THIS WAS JUST
DEALING WITH THE SPECIFIC ISSUE
WITH SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS. IN
MY DISTRICT.
WHO ARE ARE IN A SITUATION
WHERE TO LEAST SMALL AMOUNTS OF
SPACE FROM YOU KNOW WE WANNA
JUST IN SHORT THAT THEY'RE
PROTECTED AND? THAT THEY HAVE AS
A BASIC DISCLOSURE THAT THEY CAN
UNDERSTAND EVEN IF THEIR ENGLISH
SKILLS PROBABLY AREN'T. UP TO
PAR.
OKAY.
AND THEN.
APPRECIATE THAT.
THAT MY LAST QUESTION RELATES
TO.
I I GUESS WHAT WE'RE GOING FOR
WITH THE TIMING AYE IS I READ
SECTION SEE.
IT SAYS AS SOON AS PRACTICABLE.
YOU SHALL PROVIDE THE WRITTEN
DISCLOSURE A ONCE THE LICENSEE
COMMENCES LICENSE ACTIVITY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WHAT THAT
MEANS BUT THAT MIGHT BE. ME NOT
KNOWING ANYTHING ABOUT REAL
STATUS BUT WHAT WHAT IS THE IDEA
FOR WHEN THIS SEEMS LIKE YOU
WANT THE DISCLOSURE OF THAT IF.
YOU WANT TO BE AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE AND IT JUST.
DONE ONCE AND RIGHT IS
SORT OF.
MY VIEW OF.
HOW YOU WOULD OPERATE
EFFICIENTLY AND THAT IS THAT
WE'RE DOING HERE IS THAT THE
EARLY IN ONCE OR IS IT? LIKE A
DUPLICATE OF THING THAT'S GOING
TO BE DONE AT VARIOUS.
TIMES OF PEOPLE MIGHT GET.
KENNECOTT A TRAP WHERE THEY
DON'T INTEND TO VIOLATE THE LAW.
OUR INTENTION IS.
TO LIVE ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY
WHERE SOMEBODY IS NOT ALLEGING
IN OUT I TALK TO YOU THREE TIMES
NEED AND DISCLOSE THE CONFLICT
BUT YOU'RE ENTERING INTO A
RELATIONSHIP WITH.
THE AGENT.
AT IF THAT IS AN AREA THAT I
THINK WE COULD BENEFIT FROM
HAVING THE INDUSTRIES AND PUT
ON.
I THINK THEY ARE CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO DO AND
THEY IN FACT STATED THAT WHERE
WOULD WE PROBABLY MISSED THE
MARKET WOULD BE GREAT TO. HAVE
SOME PROPOSED LANGUAGE IF THEY
FEEL LIKE THAT DOES MISS THE
MARK I'M WITH YOU KNOW IT'S AYE
AYE. AYE ALSO NOT IN THE
INDUSTRY IT'S VERY HARD SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH BOTH
SIDES OF THE INDUSTRY THOSE THAT
REPRESENT ONLY TENANTS IN THOSE
THAT DO TO AGENTS. TECH TO COME
UP WITH THE APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE
SO IT'S NOT A GOTCHA IT'S NOT
MEANT TO BE A GOTCHA IT'S MEANT.
TO ENSURE THAT FOLKS ARE
INFORMED TIME IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
PRIOR TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY'RE JUST SITE READY SIGNING
THE LEASE.
AND YOU KNOW JUST GOING THROUGH
ALL THE DISCLOSURES WHICH OFTEN
HAPPENS NOW AND THAT.
PEEPER CLEAR IN THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT THEY HOLD WITH
A WITH AGENT.
OKAY YEAH I DON'T I DON'T.
MS US QUESTION I DON'T KNOW
UNKNOWN OF WHAT COMMENCES LESSIG
TO MAYBE THAT MAY THAT IS RIGHT
LANGUAGE. MAYBE IT SHOULD SAY
WHEN YOU RETAIN EVER PRO BROKER
AGENTS OR I DON'T.
MEANS I JUST I'M NOT SURE I
DON'T THINK THOUGH IT IN THE
RETAINING ASPECTS NOT LIKE
ATTORNEYS LET'S NOT SIGNED YET
RETAINER AND YOU'RE NOT GIVING
MONEY SO IT'S A KIND OF I THINK
A LITTLE BIT MORE. NEBULOUS AND
SOMETHING I THINK WE HAVE TO WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK ON TO
ENSURE IT'S NOT ABACHA.
OKAY.
A MISS ANY OF YOU ASKED IF
SOMEONE FROM OPPOSITION ALSO CAN
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
ASSUMING THAT'S WHERE YOUR THAT
WOULD DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEAS
ABOUT THAT THE TIMING ISSUE ON
WHETHER THIS LANGUAGE IN SECTION
SEE.
IS THIS THE ADEQUATE. SO WHAT I
WAS HAVING TO CLARIFY SOMETHING
AND BEEN SAD THAT ME I'M
DISCLOSURES ARE GIVEN AT THE END
OF THE TRANSACTION AND UNDER
CURRENT LAW. THE DISCLOSURE MUST
BE GIVEN PRIOR TO THE
PRESENTATION OF AN OFFER SO IN
IN A SALE SITUATION. THEY MUST
BE PRESENTED TO THE BUYER PRIOR
TO AN OFFER BEING PRESENT INTO
THE CELLAR SO ALESSI'S LESSORS
SITUATION IT'S THE SAME THING
IT'S NOT OCCURRING AT THE END OF
THE TRANSACTION.
IT'SOCCURRING PRIOR TO AN OFFER
BEING PRESENTED
SO WOULD OFFER TO THE SPACE.
IT IS NOT GOING TO WE'RE NOT
STREAMLINING THE DISCLOSURE
PROCESS WE ARE ADDING A THIRD
DISCLOSURE SO THIS DISCLOSURE AS
REQUIRED BY THE SPELL. WOULD
COME AT SOME NEBULOUS TIME THAT
WERE UNSURE OF WHEN THAT HAPPENS
AS AND SOON AS PRACTICABLE IS
LEADING TO TING CURRENT LAW BUT
THIS IS AS SOON AS PRACTICABLE.
UPON THE BEGINNING OF LICENSE
ACTIVITY BUT LICENSE ACTIVITY
CAN OCCUR BEFORE EVEN TO
RELATIONSHIP EVER OCCURS
SO WE INFORMING SOMEONE WHO IS
NOT OUR CLIENT.
THAT.
THERE'S THE POSSIBILITY OF
AGENTS OF DUAL AGENCY IT'S JUST
IT'S VERY UNCLEAR AS TO WHEN
THIS WOULD OCCUR WHAT ITS
PURPOSE IS AND IF IT WOULD
ACHIEVE ITS GOALS.
SO. ASSUMING THEY WERE ABLE TO
FIGURE THAT OUT ITS IT IS STILL
A THIRD DISCLOSURE.
I'VE AGENCY.
OKAY PUTTING ASIDE THE THE.
THE NUMBER OF DISCLOSURES FOR
SECONDS FOCUSING ON.
THE.
WHAT WHAT IS IT THAT TYPICALLY
CREATES THE AGENCY RELATIONSHIP?
I UNDERSTAND.
AND THE OTHERS VERY RIGHT IT'S
NOT LIKE.
A RETAINER AGREEMENT YOU SOME
OF THE LAWYER GETS A LITTLE BIT
MORE AMBIGUOUS OR NEBULOUS I
GUESS BUT. I MEAN WHAT WHAT IS
THAT TYPICAL TRIGGERING OF THAT.
I DON'T KNOW THERE IS A TYPICAL
TRIGGERING A THAT THERE IS AYE
THERE'S A VARIETY OF TRIGGERING
EVENTS THAT CAN OCCUR THAT CAN
ESTABLISH AGENCY.
.
TYPICALLY ONCE A WEEK LICENSEES
BEGINS TO ENGAGE.
IN LICENSE ACTIVITIES FOR.
THE PART THAT SAME YOU CALL ME I
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT A PROPERTY
I GIVE YOU INFORMATION ABOUT
THAT PROPERTY WEEK ARE ARGUABLY
IN AN AGENCY RELATIONSHIP.
AND IF IF YOU CALL ME AND ASK ME
DE CHRISTINE DO YOU KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS PROPERTY ARE
THEIR LEAKS R. THERE YOU KNOW IS
THERE MOLD AND IF I ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. WERE PROBABLY ARGUABLY
IN AN AGENCY RELATIONSHIP.
SO.
I AM WHEN WE ENTER INTO AN
AGENCY RELATIONSHIP I HAVE DUDE
I'D FIDUCIARY DUTIES YOU AMONGST
OTHER DUTIES AND SO.
WHAT?
ONCE THAT AGENCY RELATIONSHIP IS
ESTABLISHED UNDER CURRENT LAW.
THE DISCLOSURE PROCESS FOLLOWS
QUITE QUICKLY PRIOR TO
SUBMITTING AN OFFER.
SO YOU WOULD HAVE YOU WOULD.
WE'RE JUST NOT SURE HOW.
IS THIS REALLY GONNA HAPPEN
EARLIER IS REALLY GOING TO BE
MUCH EARLIER THAN THE EXISTING
LAW. AND IS IT REALLY GOING TO
ACHIEVE WHAT THE GOAL IS. WE ARE
VERY CLEAR WE SUPPORT CLEAR AND
FULL DISCLOSURE OF AGENCY
RELATIONSHIP.
A HUNDRED PERCENT.
WE SPONSORED AGENCY LA WE WE
HUNDRED PERCENT.
PLEASE ONLY.
ARE WITH HER ON THAT BUT WE JUST
CANNOT IN ITS CURRENT FORM IT'S
TO UNCLEAR IT'S TOO AMBIGUOUS
AND IT'S JUST NOT READY TO GO.
BUT IN IN TO ANSWER PART OF THAT
THAT QUESTION IF YOU'LL NOTICE
IN SEE.
THE HOOPS AND I JUST LOST IT
THAT IT'S.
THE LICENSEE COMMENCES LIGHTS
ACTIVITY ON A COMMERCIAL REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTION FOR A
PRINCIPLE.
SO THE LANGUAGE IS BUILT IN THIS
NOTION.
ESTABLISHMENT PROBABLY THAT THAT
THE THE AGENCIES THAT
RELATIONSHIP IS PROBABLY ALREADY
BEEN ESTABLISHED SINCE THERE IS
IN FACT AS A PRINCIPAL IN THERE.
SO THE NOTION WAS TO TRY IT AND
ESTABLISH.
AND NOTICE
THAT IS.
FOR AN OFFER NECESSARILY HAS
BEEN TENDERED BUT EARLY ON IN
THE RELATIONSHIP.
WHEN THERE IS ACTIVITY WHEN
AGENCY HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED AT
LEAST TO SOME EXTENT THAT BAN
THE TENANT HAS KNOWLEDGE BEFORE
GOING ANY FURTHER. OF THE
POTENTIAL BEFORE.
A CONFLICT OF INTEREST THINK
THAT WAS THE INTENT AND THAT'S
WHY THAT LANGUAGE WAS WRITTEN
THAT WAY TO TO TRY AND BUILD IN
THE NOTION OF OF AGENCY ALREADY.
SCULLY.
JUST A BRIEF WE FOLLOW UP ON NOW
ARE VICE CHAIRS AYE QUESTIONS SO
I I. I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH YOU
THAT.
I THINK THAT THE PARTIES TO ONE
OF THESE TRANSACTIONS.
SHOULD NOW IF THERE'S A DUAL
AGENCY AND SEEN THAT THE
OPPOSITION AGREES THAT TO.
.
I THINK MR FUSE YOU SAID THAT
THE EXISTING DISCLOSURES ARE ARE
INEFFECTIVE RIGHT.
AND SO DOES THIS BILL SUPERSEDE
THOSE EXISTING INEFFECTIVE
DISCLOSURES.
OR DOES IT EVEN PLACE.
NOT SURE THAT IT LEAVES THEM A
PLACE BECAUSE EXISTING
DISCLOSURES DON'T JUST HAVE TO
DO WITH DUAL AGENCY IT'S ON A
VERY SAFE YOU SEE TINY PRINT TWO
PAGE FORM WHICH INCLUDES.
THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF A
BUYER'S AGENT THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF A SELLER'S AGENT SO IT'S AN
AGENCY DISCLOSURE IT'S NOT
SPECIFIC TO THE INDIVIDUAL DUAL
EGYPT RIGHT SO. SO IT'S THE SAME
DISCLOSURE THAT.
THAT YOU AS A TENANT AT THAT HE
HE SOLELY REPRESENTS TENANTS AT
THE SAME DISCLOSURE HE HAS TO
PRESENT HIS CLIENTS AS A DUAL
AGENT DOES. AND YOU BASICALLY
HAVE TO READ THROUGH ALL THE
SMALL FINE PRINT TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT.
WHAT SITUATION YOU'RE AN ICE?
YOU KNOW THERE'S A WAY TO
CONSOLIDATE ALL OF THIS AND ONE
AND A SIMPLER FORM.
I THINK YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS
THE PUBLIC DISCLOSURE DRAPER AND
SO I HAVE IN A NUMBER OF OTHER
AREAS TRIED TO SIMPLIFY AND
MAKE.
MORE COMMON LANGUAGE FOR A
DISCLOSURE WHERE THERE'S A
SPECIFIC ISSUE THE SPECIFIC
ISSUE IS WHEN HAVE A BUYER'S
AGENT OR SELLER'S AGENT YOU
DON'T HAVE THE POSSIBILITY OF A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST. WHEN YOU
HAVE A DELAYED AND SEE YOU HAVE
A VERY REAL AND WE KNOW THAT IN.
IN LA ON OUT A VERY REAL IN AS
ATTORNEYS EVEN LIKE. A I THINK
WE CAN BE A LITTLE CONFUSED HAVE
A FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY TO
BOTH THE BUYER AND THE SELLER.
I CAN IMAGINE THAT THAT'S VERY
TOUGH I I'M NOT EVEN SURE HOW.
SOMEBODY DOES THAT BUT I'M GONNA
NOT WE'RE NOT GOING THERE I'D
YOU KNOW STARTED THEREIN.
WE'RE NOT GONNA GO THERE BUT
THAT DAY IS SO.
WERE TRYING TO GET TO THAT CASE
THAT WHEN THERE'S LITTLE AGENCY
WHEN IT'S CLEAR THAT A AN AGENT
IS REPRESENTING BOTH SIDES THAT
THERE JUST CLEAR WITH THE
CONSUMER. I'M WE'RE NOT TRYING
TO TO STACK THE DECK WE JUST
THINK THAT THAT THE CONSUMER THE
CLOUD THE. OUTSIDE TENANT HAS
HAS THE RIGHT IN SHOULD KNOW
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH OF MEGA CORPORATIONS THAT
THE PERSON WHO IS REPRESENTING
YOU IS ALSO REPRESENTING THE
LAMB ART.
EARLY ON I MEAN I GUESS WE COULD
TAKE THE DUAL AGENCY BUT THAT
THERE'S OTHER SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
I HATE THESE THINGS I DON'T KNOW
I DON'T KNOW EYES AND. LET'S BE
HONEST I MEAN WE'VE DONE THIS
FOR YEARS IT'S LIKE THE.
THE THE POSTERS THAT WE PUT UP
ON LABOR LAW LIKE AT SOME POINT
IT'S BECOME SO RIDICULOUS AND
THIS ISN'T THE ONLY DISCLOSURE
FORM THAT THEY'RE FIGHTING. SO
THIS IS WHAT I DO HERE. HERE
SIGN THIS OKAY AND BY THE WAY
HERE'S THAT THE OFFICIAL OFFERS
I'VE DONE IT BEFORE THE OFFERING
HERE'S THE OTHER EIGHT PAGES OF
DISCLOSURE THAT I HAVE TO GIVE
YOU ABOUT EVERYTHING IN THE
WORLD. AM WELL YOU KNOW I I
GUESS.
WHERE PRODUCT OF OUR OWN?
AND HOW DOES THIS HELP THE
SITUATION BECAUSE WHEN YOU COME
TO ME SAY HEY.
KEVIN WE'RE GOING TO WORK YOU
KNOW I WORKED WITH YOU BEFORE I
LOOK INTO PLACE IT'S DOWN THE
STREET YOU KNOW CAN YOU CHECK
THIS OUT FOR ME AND YOU SAY. I
I'D LOVE TO I I NEED TO GIVE YOU
THIS I'M HERE.
VERY SIMPLE ME GIVE YOU.
TWO PARAGRAPHS I'M A DUAL AGENT.
YOU MIGHT CONSIDER THAT A
CONFLICT MAYBE NOT.
BUT.
HE SIGNED US BEFORE WE ENTERED
INTO THIS.
OKAY I'M I MEAN I CERTAINLY LIKE
BE IN INTENDED JUST SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE GONNA NOW HAVE.
EVEN IF WE ASSUME THAT THIS IS
AN EFFECTIVE DISCLOSURE THAT
WHEN IT IS SOMETIMES NOT
NECESSARILY CONVINCED OUT NOW WE
HAVE TO AN EFFECTIVE DISCLOSURE
THAN ONE EFFECT IS CLOSURE AND
I'M.
NOT SURE HOW THAT IMPROVE THE
SITUATIONS I GUESS. WHAT I'D
LIKE TO SEE IS ALL THE PARTIES
WHO SEEM TO AGREE ON THE
PRINCIPLE OF OF EFFECTIVE
DISCLOSURE TO TRY TO? ACTUALLY
MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
WHICH I I'M JUST NOT SURE THIS
REALLY DOES THAT.
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO TAKE
SUGGESTIONS I HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON THE SPELL FOR A HERE FLAT.
AND I. YOU KNOW IT NOT EVERYBODY
SEEMS TO WANT COULD NOT HAVE
PROBLEMS BUT NOT OFFER OF
SOLUTIONS TO PROBLEMS SO. I HAD.
THIS THIS TO ME IS VERY CLEAR
IT'S IT'S A COUPLE SENTENCES
THAT TELL SOMEBODY WIENER
INTERNING INTO A RELATIONSHIP
THAT THERE COULD POSSIBLY IT
COULD BE A CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
THAT'S IT.
ISRAEL.
THANK YOU.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
THE REAL ESTATE WOULD YOU DO
HAVE SOME WHO HAVE MORE
KNOWLEDGE SOME WILL HAVE LESS
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
I THINK THAT.
FULL DISCLOSURE.
TRANSPARENCY OR ARE VERY
IMPORTANT OR TWO AREAS AND THEY
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED.
ALREADY.
BUT I AM.
STILL CONFUSED ABOUT SEE. ABOUT.
THE LICENSED ACTIVITY.
TO
WHAT DEFINES A LICENSE LICENSED
ACTIVITY BUT I'M HEARING FROM
YOU THAT THAT IS AN AREA THAT
YOU'RE WILLING TO TALK TO THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT. AND I FROM THE
OPPOSITION SOUNDS LIKE THEY HAVE
IDEAS ON WHAT LICENCED ACTIVITY
WOULD TO BE.
SO THAT IS AN AREA THAT YOU ARE
STILL WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE YOU GET.
THAT DEFINED.
WELL THERE IS A DEFINITION.
FOR LICENSE ACTIVITY IN THE BNP
CODE AND IT'S ANY ACTION THAT
REQUIRES AN INDIVIDUAL TO BE
LICENSED TO DO THAT.
SO I THINK THAT'S CLEAR IF THAT
IF IF THERE IS A REASON WHY THAT
DOESN'T WORK.
FOR THE OPPOSITION WOULD BE
HAPPY TO.
MAKE THAT MORE CLEAR AYE BUT
THERE IT'S IN DEFINITION IT'S
JUST THAT YOU KNOW IF THEY NEED
A FLEXIBILITY OF TOM AND I
DON'T.
THE PROBLEM I MEAN NONE OF US
KNOW THE EXACT AND.
INDUSTRY I DON'T THINK ANYONE ON
ON THIS PANEL BUT IF THEY'RE
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
FLEXIBILITY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
AVOID.
IS THAT SITUATION WHERE YOU SIT
DOWN WITH SOMEBODYAND YOU GIVE
THEM. THIS DISCLOSURE WHICH.
ONLY ONE THIRD OF RELATES TO
YOU NO MATTER WHO YOU ARE
BECAUSE THERE'S THREE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES DESCRIBED HERE.
AND THEN YOU SIGN AND THEN YOU
GET THE FORMAL OFFER ALTHOUGH
YOU COULD HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THE OFFER IS. AND.
WITH ALL THE PARAMETERS SQUARE
FOOTAGE TRIPLE NET WHATEVER IT
IS RIGHT AND THEN YOU'RE GIVEN
THAT.
I THINK IT'S AN EIGHT PAGE
DISCLOSURE VERY LENGTHY
ADDITIONAL DISCLOSURE WHERE E..
YOU KNOW YOU JUST.
EVERYTHING BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
WE DO NOW.
WHAT WE TRY TO AVOID IS THAT
SITUATION WHERE UP FRONT WHEN
WE'RE DEALING WITH LOOKING FOR A
PLACE I'M A TENANT?
I'M A SMALL BUSINESS WHO JUST
WANTS TO FIND A PLACE TO PUT MY
D'ELIA GOT THREE POSSIBLE AREAS
TO BE IN THAT AREA THAT I WANT
TO BE. AND I CALL SOMEBODY AND
SAY IN THAT THERE LIKE THEY KNOW
THAT THEY REPRESENT ALSO THAT
THE LANDLORDS IN THOSE THREE
AREAS BUT THEY'RE JUST UP FRONT
THAT'S ALL WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN
UP FRONT IMPROVE IT BY. TWO
SENTENCES THAT SAY I MIDDLE
AGED.
IF THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
THAT I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
CONCERN IS.
I THINK IT'S GOOD FOR PEOPLE
HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
AGENTS AND TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
THAT SO IF WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT.
FURTHER CLARIFY WHAT LICENSE
ACTIVITY WHAT WOULD TRIGGER.
A SITUATION BY WHICH I THINK WE
CAN USE LIT WE DID UNITS LOOSE
LANGUAGE ON THE LICENSE ACTIVITY
BECAUSE IT WE STILL GIVE THEM
YOU KNOW.
CALLIE.
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE ON THE PHONE
AND SOMEBODY'S CALLING YOU AND
ASKING YOU KNOW YOU YOU MIGHT
HAVE TO DO WHEN YOU'RE IN PERSON
AND SEE THEM RIGHT I'M.
SO.
I'D BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THAT'S WHY I THINK
I THINK IT'S EASY TO SAY WELL
LET'S NOT DO IT BECAUSE I'M.
BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION WILL
PROVIDE POSSIBLE LANGUAGE.
THE OTHER AREA WAS ON THE ON
THE.
DISCIPLINE ACTION THAT ASPECT OF
IT.
WHERE?
IT AND IT CAN GO UP TO LOSING
THE LICENSE BUT IT INCLUDES
ASSOCIATED LICENSEES.
IT.
IS THERE SOME WORD THAT
DESCRIBES THE THE CONDUCT AND.
IN THE QUESTION WAS ASKED BY.
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM.
IS THAT WHAT POINT IS AT THE TO
GET TO LOSE A LICENSE AND IF
YOU'RE AN ASSOCIATE LICENSEE DO
YOU HAVE TO HAVE WORKED ON THAT
TRANSACTION BECAUSE I WASN'T
CLEAR FROM THE LANGUAGE. IS THAT
EVERYBODY ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
FIRM FOR THAT THE REALTOR WHO DO
ENTERED INTO THE TRANSACTION. O.
IS IT SOMEONE WHO PARTICIPATED
OR JUST IS A MEMBER OF THAT
EIGHT DATA FIRM. SO.
IF I CAN'T AFFORD TO THE
COMMITTEE A TWENTY HELPED US
WITH THIS LANGUAGE I BELIEVE AND
I'M AYE. I UNDERSTOOD THAT WE
WERE AYE.
PUTTING INTO THE BILL WHAT WAS
IN EXISTENCE THE BNP BECAUSE.
I'M FOR POSSIBLE PENALTY.
I DON'T WANNA MISS STATE THOUGH
IF I GOT MY AROUND.
YEAH I THINK THAT'S TRUE IN THIS
IS.
THIS IS LIFTING SORT OF WHAT WAS
IN EXISTENCE AND AND PUTTING IT
IN HERE GIVING THE.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
ABILITY TO TO LEVY.
PENALTIES IN IN CASES IN AYE I
GUESS EFICACES EGREGIOUS ENOUGH
OF THIS SECTION DOES DESCRIBE.
POTENTIAL.
MALFEASANCE THAT'S MUCH BROADER
THAT WHAT WE'RE SPECIFICALLY
TALKING ABOUT HERE AND AS IT WAS
OFFER BEFORE PERHAPS IT IS
BETTER JUST MAKE A CROSS
REFERENCE.
TO BACK TO THIS PROVISION IN
BEING PAY.
YEAH I DON'T THINK WERE TRYING
TO CREATE A NEW SYSTEM BY WHICH
SOMEBODY IS THE US JAPAN BUT USE
THE EXISTING SYSTEM WHERE ALL
THESE THINGS ARE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT DEPENDING LIKE.
OBVIOUSLY IF THERE IS A FRAUD BY
AN ENTIRE AGENCIES ARE AT A TIRE
FIRM TO DETECT.
DEFRAUD PEOPLE PERHAPS EVERYBODY
WOULD LOSE THEIR LICENCE WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO CREATE SOMETHING
NOW SO I I'D BE HAPPY TO JUST
SIMPLY REFERENCE.
ANOTHER SECTION.
BUT THANK YOU.
THANK MISTER CHAIR I JUST HAVE A
STATEMENT AND MY APOLOGIES I'D
WANTED TO.
BE HERE FOR THE ENTIRE
DISCUSSION I'M JUGGLING A COUPLE
OF COMMITTEES. ON I WAS REALLY
SURPRISED IN THE INTERIM HOW
MANY MEDIA REQUESTS I WAS ASKED
TO TAKE ABOUT THIS BILL.
AND AND FIRST I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT IT IS NOT AT
THIS MOMENT A BAN ON DUAL
AGENCIES AND YOU'VE SHIFTED IT
TO DISCLOSURE. I DO THINK THAT
THERE STILL IS LACK OF CLARITY
IN THE LANGUAGE AND.
IF THIS COMMITTEE WANTS TO MOVE
IT FORWARD.
AND IF I SUPPORTED HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE ARM I JUST WANNA SAY
UP FRONT THAT I'M GONNA RESERVE
MY RIGHT AND MY VOTE ON THE
FLOOR DEPENDING AYE WITH
LANGUAGE GOES BECAUSE I DO HOPE.
THAT IT WILL GET TO CLEAR PLACE
AND.
AND AND I WAS CURIOUS YOU
MENTIONED THAT OPPOSITION HAS
NOT YET GIVEN LANGUAGE TOO
CLARIFIED I WOULD REALLY
ENCOURAGE OBVIOUSLY ALL OF EVER
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO TO
HOPEFULLY COME TO THE TABLE AND
GET TO A BETTER RESULT. AREI
THINK WE ALL KNOW HOW CONFUSING
THESE DISCLOSURES CAN BE AND AND
I CERTAINLY AM ONE WHO.
AT LEAST IN DIFFERENT REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTIONS I'VE SEEN IN
MY TIME.
THE IT'S VERY CONFUSING AND AND
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE ALL
WANT CLARITY I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON THAT PRINCIPLE THE
QUESTION IS HOW WE GET THERE SO.
I IF THIS COMMITTEE
DOES THINK WE SHOULD MOVE THIS
FORWARD.
JUST WANNA. RESERVE AGAIN.
DISCUSSION A IN THE FUTURE ON
CLARITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS JUST OLD THANK YOU
I'D.
MY APOLOGIES I HAVE TO.
GET TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE THAT'S
NOW ENDED UP BUT I DID WANT TO
BE HERE AND BE A PART OF THE AT
LEAST HEAR THE PRESENTATION I
THINK I.
CERTAIN BEEN CLEAR THROUGH THE
PROCESS WHEN THIS WAS MORE OF AN
AGGRESSIVE BILL ON DUAL AGENCY
MY OPPOSITION.
I'M STILL NOT THERE.
I FEEL THAT.
AND AS I REVIEW THE DOCUMENTS
AND I ALSO SEE HELD SOME OF. YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE SMALL NUMBER OF OPPONENTS
OR OR PROPONENTS AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE OPPOSED BUT THESE ARE ALL
PEOPLE WITHIN THE INDUSTRY. WHO
ARE?
SINGING FROM THE SAME HYMN BOOK
AND AS A.
AS A LICENSE.
AGENT AND. BROKER IN THE STATE.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE I
THAT OPERATE UNDER THESE.
OUR GUIDELINES FOR A VERY LONG
TIME AND HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OPERATE UNDER
DUAL AGENCY. AND I WILL NEVER
SAY THAT ANYTHING IS PERFECT I
WILL NEVER SAY THAT. IT
ACCOMPLISHES EVERYTHING THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
HAPPEN BUT I DO THINK THAT.
AND AND WHEN AGENTS AREN'T
PERFORMING UNDER THE THE
GUIDELINES AS THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO THERE IS RECOURSE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT.
CAN THIS BE MADE BETTER.
PROBABLY CAN BE.
IS THIS TE APPROACH THAT GETS
US THERE.
I'M NOT THERE YET AND AND SO I
WILL BE LAYING OFF THE BILL
TODAY.
SHOULD IT OF PROGRESS IN THE
PROCESS.
THEN I KNOW THAT THE OPPOSITION
WILL NEED TO COME TOGETHER AND
SORT OF BE CLEAR I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS ANOTHER TRACK THAT
THE SEEMINGLY R. ON WHICH I
WASN'T CLEAR OF.
UNTIL. OF THE ONE SPEAKER SHARE
THAT WITH US IN TERMS THE BE BE
MP PROCESS. OB SO I THINK THAT'S
GOOD BUT I DO.
I THINK THAT IF THERE.
WAS AN OPPORTUNITY THAT THEY
COULD HAVE TAKEN AND DID NOT
TAKE.
TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU TO TRY TO
BE AT LEAST CLEAR ON WHAT THEY
CAN.
AT TO THIS BILL AS IT RELATES TO
DIS.
S. TYPE OF DISCLOSURE.
THEN THEY SHOULD HAVE.
BUT THAT WOULD NOTWITHSTANDING.
MY OWN PERSONAL.
.
EXPERIENCE
THROUGH THIS PROCESS WOULD LEAD
ME NOT TO BE THERE TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY BUT I JUST WANTED TO.
BEFORE I RUN OUT OF HERE BEFORE
THE VOTE I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
SHARING THAT WITH.
THANK YOU SMIDGE AYE.
I WOULD LIKE TO KEEP MY FLIGHT
HOME AS ENJOYABLE AS POSSIBLE SO
I'M GONNA EXPLAIN OPERANT MATT
TODAY.
SO I HAVE SOME THOUGHTS.
I HAVE SOME THOUGHTS.
IN IT FOR SEPTEMBER CENTRALLY I
MET WITH PROPONENTS YESTERDAY.
AND AT THAT TIME I DID HAVE A
COPY THE BELLS AYE I JUST
HAVEN'T READ IT YET SO I WILL BE
LAYING OUT TODAY JUST FOR THAT
REASON BUT I DO HAVE SOME
THOUGHTS ABOUT GOING FORWARD. I
LIKE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO I
THINK THE DISCLOSURE AND
TRANSPARENCY THINGS GREAT. YOU
IRONICALLY ON THIS PAST MONEY
BECAUSE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
HELPING OUT PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
SOPHISTICATED BUT THE BUT THE
PROPONENTS
AND THE OPPONENTS ARE HIGHLY
SOPHISTICATED SO IT SEEMS LIKE
ON SOME OF THIS LANGUAGE THAT
THERE OUGHT TO BE WAIT. TO GET
TOGETHER AND SORT OF WORK OUT.
THE YOU KNOW EVERYBODY UP HERE
IS EITHER TRYING TO YOU KNOW
LIKE WE ARE A LITTLE BIT TRYING
TO PLAY LAWYER OR.
TRYING TO WORK OUT SOME THESE.
ISSUES FROM HERE AND IT'S IT'S
DIFFICULT IT SEEMS LIKE THERE
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO BE AN
EXCHANGE OF LANGUAGE THAT WORKS
OUT THESE THINGS SO. I'M GLAD I
KNOW YOU I KNOW YOU'VE WORKED A
LOT ON THIS FOR A LONG TIME SO.
I AND I STILL ONE I AT STAY
INVOLVED IN IT I GET SOME OTHER
THOUGHT ON ON SOME OF THE POINTS
THAT OTHER PEOPLE RAISING THAT
MAY GO. SOME WAY TOWARDS
GETTING.
READ OF SOME OF THESE ISSUES ARE
AND YOU HAD MENTIONED SORT OF
THE LABOR YOU KNOW ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU KNOW YOU GO ON A
BREAK FROM ANYWHERE. AND IT'S
JUST WALL TO WALL FINE PRINT AND
AND SO AS A RESULT NO ONE READS
IT RIGHT RIGHT.
.
BUT YET ON SOME SINCE WE STILL
KEEP DO HERE RIGHT WE STILL KEEP
THAT OUT HAVING THEM PUT UP ORE
WHEN THEY'RE NOT READING THE
ONES THAT ARE THERE. WITH SOME
OF THESE I THINK I'VE YOU KNOW I
GET AGAIN JUST FROM THAT SORT OF
THE TESTIMONY TODAY WHAT I'M.
YOU KNOW SORT OF IMPLYING FROM
BEING UP HERE. IS.
THAT SOME OF THE CONCERN THAT
THE OPPONENTS HAVE IS
WE CAN OTHERS MULTIPLE FORMS.
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT REALLY SURE
AND IN THE PENALTY COULD BE
SEVERE RIGHT IT COULD BE VERY
SEVERE ARE NOT REALLY SURE LIKE
HOW MANY FORMS. IN IN ESSENCE R.
ARE AT NOW HAVING THREE FOUR
THREE FORMS ISN'T GONNA MAKE
EVEN IF ONE OF THEM SIMPLER.
ISN'T GONNA MAKE THE OVERALL
PROCESS SIMPLER WHAT WE'VE DONE
A LOT OF TIMES THEY LIKE WITH
BUYING A HOUSE RIGHT WE DID ALL
THESE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THAT
ALL THESE REFORMS. AND WHAT IT
ENDED UP DOING IS YOU GET A
STACK THIS BIG AND YOU MAY SEE
YOU KNOW THE FIRST FIVE OR SIX
SEVEN YOU'RE READING BUT BY THE
END YOU'RE JUST SIGNING.
EVERYTHING I.
.
SO I MEAN I YOU KNOW I'D I'D BE
HAPPY TO STAY INVOLVED YOU KNOW
WHERE TO FIND ME AND THE GUY
SITTING NEXT YEAR ON THE PLANE.
SO I'D BE HAPPY TO KNOW THAT
IT'S LIKE. THAT.
BUT I.%
LIVE THE DRINK COUPONS SO.
HOW DOES NOT GIVE YOU MINE?
I'VE STILL GOT A LOT.
MANY MATT I'M CERTAINLY WOULD
LIKE TO HELP.
WOULD LIKE TO SEE OBVIOUSLY SEE
IT ACTUAL COPY OF THE BILL.
AND AND READ IT.
.
AND THEN CERTAINLY WOULD.
YOU KNOW BE INCLINED AS IT
COMES AS GETS MORE THROUGH THAT
PROCESS TAKE
CONTINUE WORKING ON IT SO
DOCUMENTS CHAO.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT SING NONE WAS CONSULT
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I AM I JUST YOU KNOW. THIS HAS
BEEN A YEAR LONG PROCESS.
AND I'VE LEARNED A LOT AYE I
STILL BELIEVE THAT MY JOB HERE
IS TO REPRESENT MY CONSTITUENTS
AND WHEN. I'M.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE TYPE OF AGREEMENTS THAT MY
CONSTITUENTS
AT.
HAVE TO ENTER. I'M WHO ARE NOT
SOPHISTICATED OFTEN DON'T HAVE
ATTORNEYS I HAVE NO IDEA ON A
TRIPLE FORM OF AGENCY HAD
DISCLOSURES WHICH ONE THERE'D
BEEN FALLING UNTIL. THAT WE ARE
SELLING THEM SHORT.
I'M
YES THERE IS A LOT OF OPPOSITION
MISTER HOLDEN WAS CRACKED.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE INDUSTRY.
ITEM THAT HAS TO BE DISCLOSED
UPON AS IS VERY LARGE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT. THE INDUSTRY
THAT REPRESENTS ONLY TENANTS OR
TENANTS THEMSELVES IS VERY
SMALL.
A IT'S A IT'S WE HAVE IT A HUGE
IMBALANCE OF POWER HERE IN
THAT'S OFTEN WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO CRACK THINGS SO.
I'M I'M A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED
AYE GIVEN HOW MUCH I HAVE
CHANGED THAT SPELL. ITEM AND NOT
GOING TOWARDS BEGINNING TO
AGENCY ALTHOUGH THERE ARE MANY
AND AND WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE THIS
OUT.
.
I BELIEVE HONESTLY I'M
UNFORTUNATELY THAT THE OPPONENTS
AT OPPOSITE OPPOSE MUST AMENDED
THEY DID HAVE LANGUAGE.
THAT THAT THEIR LACK OF ABILITY
TO PROVIDE THAT LANGUAGE IS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW. BY NOT DOING
THAT THAT YOU WOULD BE STUCK IN
A SITUATION OF YES OR NO.
I'M.
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY AS THINGS
MOVE FORWARD TO LOOK AT.
AT THE INDUSTRY WHO'S
CONTROLLING THE SITUATION THERE
FIX IS TO IT.
THINK THOSE BILLS COME TO MY
COMMITTEE.
BUT I I WOULD LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I WOULD ASK FOR
A PERSONAL OPPORTUNITY CA TEAM
OF THIS BILL FORD SO THAT WE
COULD ACTUALLY. I FORCED THE
OPPOSITION TO IT TO WORK ON SOME
LANGUAGE AND TO SUBMIT WHAT THAT
AMENDMENT WOULD LOOK LIKE TO
ACTUALLY NEGOTIATE.
ON.
I RESPECT THE ASPIRIN ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
I'M LOOKING FOR A MOTION THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
SECOND.
SO IF YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CHAO.
CHARGE YOU.
I HURT
CHIU AYE GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES.
THAT HAS FOR.
SO WILL. LEAVE FEDERAL OPEN FOR
A LITTLE BIT.
THIS MAIENSCHEIN YOU CAN.
YES.
I REYES AYE.
THAT'S STILL NEEDS ONE MORE.
WE'LL GO THROUGH THE ROLE AS WE.
AND IF IF IT'S NOT SUCCESSFUL.
JUDGE ITO'S RECONSIDERATION I
WOULD PLACE THANK YOU. WE WILL
TAKE THAT UP.
MISTER MAY TELL YOU WANNA MAKE A
MOTION ON DOCTOR REGULAR SKILLET
NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY NINE.
OKAY WILL TAKE ONE AT A TIME SO.
HIS ME ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TOLD
EIGHTY NINE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE.
UP THAT WE NEED SECOND TO SECOND
MISTER CUNNINGHAM THANK YOU.
STONE. AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAO.
JOE AYE CHIU AYE AYE.
TO AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY AYE
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MEANTIME I RAISED.
REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT AND THEN MR
MAINTAIN YOUR MOTION. ON THE
CONSENT ITEM ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SIR SECOND.
SECOND FROM THIS GARCIA. COLOR
ROLLING CONSENT PLEASE THAT MOST
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS
STONE. AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. CHOW. CHOW AYE
CHIU AYE.
CHIU AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES.
REYES AYE.
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT.
IF WE JUST HAVE ONE MISSING
MEMBER MISTER HOLDEN IS HE
COMING BACK.
SO WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN A
COUPLE MINUTES GIVEN A CHANCE TO
COME BACK.
ACTUALLY VOTES
COMING BACK.
ALRIGHT SO CONSENT.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE
INTENT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TEN FIFTY
NINE GONZALEZ FLETCHER CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
AT THAT BILL FAILS AND THE
AUTHOR IS REQUEST DID.
RECONSIDERATION.
WHICH WE WILL.
GRANTS THAT ITEM NUMBER THREE I
AB TWELVE EIGHTY NINE RANDY.
COLDLY MEMBERS.
HOLDEN AYE.
WE ARE DONE THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH.
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED